if one wishes to discover their highest
value and status in life it is helpful
to consider the basic economic model of
supply and demand a good or service is
valued higher when there is a limited
supply of said good or service coupled
with a high desire for it likewise a
person who is unique and in low supply
but high in demand and interest to
humankind will acquire significant
higher value and status in life in order
to discover your value in this life you
must not be afraid of finding and
embracing your unique self and sharing
it with the world not everyone is a
person of low supply and high demand if
everyone was then there would no longer
be a low supply and consequently no
longer would anyone be uniquely valuable
just like how government bodies and
economies self-regulate supply and
demand
so does nature with greatness and human
value everyone possesses some form and
degree of greatness but only some of us
possess truly unique and sovereign
greatness greatness that slices through
all the noise of the world and yields
collective impact high virtue wealth
Fame and power in order to better
understand the distribution and
separation of human greatness it is
helpful to consider a species outside of
humanity the bumblebee consider the
queen bee a queen bee is born a queen
bee it is born into higher value and
status as a result of its ability to
fulfill a role that is in low supply and
high demand within its bee hive
whether the bee wants it or not it is a
queen
likewise whether you want to or not you
may possess unique greatness the
difference between bees and us is that
bees are immensely less complex human
culture is far more complicated and on a
much larger scale than that of a beehive
our higher level of consciousness and
cultural complexity imposes a
significant difference on the process of
determining who is what kind of B in the
human world unlike a beehive there is
room in the human world for far more
queen bees than the one per hive dynamic
of the bee world through mass media and
mass communication our human hives have
become enormous ly large our boundaries
extend beyond our immediately
surrounding communities and as a result
human greatness is far more widespread
complex and malleable it is therefore
the obligation of every individual both
for the benefit of themselves and the
collective quality of humankind to
oppose the resistance of life and fight
tooth and nail for their greatness in
hopes that it may be low in supply and
high in demand one must go to the end of
the world for their beliefs ideas and
ambitions one must trust that they are
worth as much as they think they are and
work untiringly throughout life to prove
it with attention conviction and action
your greatness will manifest into its
particular value and you will find out
how great it truly is
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder